hey guys we're here at CES 2012 now I
know you've seen a million-in-one iphone
camera lenses this is actually a pretty
cool one the coach at ODOT actually
films in 360° panoramic view H point 264
codec so you can basically share any of
your videos shot completely 360 around
you so I put this on the ground I lay it
in the middle of my floor and I can see
my parents you know sitting on the couch
and my cat across the room crawling on
the windowsill at the same time it's
going to be everywhere pretty soon in
Apple stores and online on amazon com as
well as Apple online for 80 bucks which
is not terribly pricey for for an iphone
lens it's new it's different its kind of
funky and you can shoot video in a weird
way that that I haven't before